in a landmark deal toward middle east
peace israel and the united arab
emirates will establish
normal diplomatic relations the surprise
announcement
came after a phone call yesterday
between president trump israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu
and leaders of the persian gulf country
it requires
israel to pause its annexation of
territory
in the west bank if both countries
fulfill the
fulfill the deal the uae will be the
only the third middle eastern nation
to have normal relations with israel
behind jordan and
egypt president trump's son-in-law and
senior adviser jared kushner led the
talks
he joins us from the white house good
morning thanks for being with us
good morning thank you for having me the
new york times columnist
tom friedman who's written a lot about
this region uh called it a geopolitical
earthquake and huge the president said
he anticipates
others in the region will follow
possibly even
the palestinians but they call this a
betrayal
who do you think is likely to follow
well i think what happened yesterday is
a tremendous day and you know our
administration doesn't always agree with
tom friedman but i think that the column
that he wrote was spot on this is
a massive change for the middle east
president trump does not take
traditional approaches i saw that in the
lead up to this segment
that people misinterpret him sometimes
with the way that he's posturing on
different things but
what you saw yesterday was the first
peace deal in the middle east in the
last 26 years
i've been working on this very closely
with president trump over the last
three and a half years it took a lot to
get to this point but this is a dramatic
breakthrough
that will make the middle east safer it
means that less american troops will
have to be over there
a lot of the past politicians created
the instability when president trump got
into office
isis had a caliphate the size of ohio we
had a lot of violence we had a lot of
terrorism
and president trump's gone very very
tough at it because his priority
is protecting american citizens so
president trump the deal maker
had a very big victory yesterday and was
able to bring our close ally
uh united arab emirates together with
our closest ally in the region israel
which will make america safer in the
region
and the whole region more hopeful
president netanyahu
says israel is still committed to
annexing parts of the west bank but
it can only happen in coordination with
the u.s and some are saying
since he's still committed to that this
is really only a symbolic victory
well not at all first of all you have
the first peace agreement in 26 years so
that's not symbolic that's concrete
but with regards to the annexation the
middle east has a lot of problems these
are problems that have been developed
over
decades and president trump's the first
person to come in very pragmatic he
moved the embassy to jerusalem he
recognized the golan heights
he ended the disastrous iran deal which
gave 150 billion dollars
to the largest state sponsor of
terrorism that chance death to america
death to israel and so president trump's
really realigned things he's also
combated
extremism he's taken out some of the
leading terrorists in the region
and that's created a much better
paradigm there so we still have to deal
with the realities on the ground we
still have a lot more work to do but
over the last three and a half years
president trump's strategy that he laid
out
in riyadh in 2017 has really been
working
and we have a lot more successes ahead
and that's why president trump's
strategy which a lot of people
discounted and under
estimated because it was unorthodox is
something that is proving to have great
results as tom friedman
called out in his column today i want to
turn to the coronavirus
because we just had the worst day for
deaths since late may
the cdc head uh robert redfield said we
could face the worst
fall in his in the history of american
health if we don't follow some basic
guidelines
and dr anthony fauci said i'm not
pleased with things are
how things are going vice president
biden in his campaign has called for a
national mass
mandate the president said he is against
that
why president trump has strongly
encouraged people to wear masks
he believes in the federalist system he
trusts americans to make the right
decisions for themselves
he trusts governors to make the right
decisions a lot of governors have put in
place mass mandates
and the president has supported them but
you have some states that have very low
transmission you have some states that
are very high and if people feel more
comfortable wearing masks
they absolutely should i do think it's a
public health
a good thing to do people should be
doing it
but president trump does not believe
that washington should be telling people
how to live their lives in all the
different states so
i i think that this is people really
politicizing this issue more than
anything else
i think we have made a lot of progress
we've gotten uh you know to the
hospitals to our country
all the different uh supplies that they
needed we've seen a lot of hysteria that
that wouldn't be possible president
trump's led
the effort to do a vaccine the fastest
vaccine in history took 13 months
to get from development to stage 3
trials on the coronavirus vaccine
president trump's done that in four
months without
bypassing any safety regulations and we
have six of them now
that are very close to being done and
we're simultaneously manufacturing doses
so that the minute it gets approved
uh we'll be able to start making it
available to those who want it so
look president trump is is making his
decisions based on the science he's been
following the advice of his advisors
he's focused on making sure that people
as few people as possible
lose their jobs and that the economic
impact from this is as little as
possible while also trying to save as
many lives as possible this is a global
pandemic it's a very tough situation
and president trump has shown great
leadership throughout this but the
science but the science mr kushner is
pretty clear that masks make a big
difference
yeah but again it's a difference between
mandating them and allowing people to do
it again he supported a lot of governors
who have been in place mandates but the
way that the federal system works is
that
the president doesn't believe that
there's a one-size-fits-all approach to
everywhere it's like education that has
to be decided on the local level
the president believes that the mask
should be decided on the local level but
he has taken a very strong stance that
he encourages all americans to wear
masks and he believes
uh that it will help us defeat this
virus even though frequently he doesn't
wear one himself
well again it's it's you're supposed to
wear one in situations i mean you
shouldn't wear a mask in the shower
when there's no one around you if you're
around people up in tester you're in the
right environment
there's no need to wear a mask but but
people should take precautions and wear
masks where appropriate so
again i think a lot of people have tried
to politicize this issue this is a
public health issue we shouldn't be
putting politics in this we should all
be focusing on what's best for the
country what's best for people
and how do we move forward but the good
news with the vaccine coming
is that with therapeutics our case
fatality rate has gone down
hospitals are knowing how to treat
people much better we're learning from
the science who has a greater risk and
who has a smaller risk
based on this disease and we keep
adjusting accordingly so
the good news is as the vaccine shows a
lot of promise hopefully that will again
and then we can rebuild the country and
president trump built the greatest
economy that our country's seen in 50
years
before the virus and i have no doubt
that he'll be able to do it again
this time even bigger and better he's
bringing a lot of our jobs back now from
china
and from other places and focused on how
do we never put ourselves in a position
where we're
vulnerable to a pandemic like this again
in a press conference yesterday
president trump promoted a false and
racist conspiracy theory that senator
kamala harris
is not eligible to be vice president
let's take a listen
to what he said in that briefing
yesterday so i just heard that
i heard it today
that she doesn't meet the requirements
and by the way the lawyer that wrote
that
piece is a very highly qualified very
talented
lawyer i have no idea if that's right i
would have though
i would have assumed the democrats would
have checked that out before she gets
chosen to run for vice president but
that's a very serious you're saying that
they're saying that she doesn't qualify
because she wasn't born in this country
does the trump campaign accept that
kamala harris is a qualified candidate
he just said that he had no idea whether
that's right or wrong i don't see that
as promoting it but
look at the end of the day it's
something that's out there
uh and again do you accept that she's a
qualified candidate
uh i personally have no reason to
believe she's not but again my focus for
the last 24 hours has been on the
historic peace deal that we've been
able to achieve here he was born in
oakland california
yeah makes her a qualified candidate
why didn't the president take the
opportunity to debunk that theory
i have not had a chance to discuss this
with him but again
let his words speak for himself you met
this week with with kanye west
who's been a friend of yours for 10
years
yes is the republican party trying to
help kanye west get on the ballot in
some states is the trump campaign trying
to do that
no look our discussion was about we were
talking about different policies kanye's
obviously a very visionary thinker he's
somebody who
cares a lot about about our country and
a lot of people
we were discussing a book that he
actually sent me a while ago called
powernomics by dr claude anderson which
is
uh which had a lot of great policy ideas
in it many of which the president's put
in place but
look president trump promised that he
would be the president for
all americans and especially represent
the forgotten americans
in this country president trump led
historic efforts to pass criminal
justice reform i was
uh fortunate to lead those efforts which
rolled back uh the crime laws
that were passed in 1994 that had a
disproportionate impact on the
african-american community
he also passed opportunity zones to get
access to capital
in a lot of the underserved areas and so
right now we're in the pandemic but a
lot of these ideas for how we can get
better schools and better capital and
better jobs into the inner cities to
those
who need it the most are ones that
president trump's very focused on so
kanye and i like to talk about ideas
like that but uh we haven't discussed
his actual campaign you didn't discuss
his campaign for president at all
uh we did not jared kushner thank you
very much
great thank you have a great day